it was it was a beautiful weekend you
guys last weekend of spring we've
already had some record heat just week
before last but boy this weekend was
just delightful 91 on saturday 88
yesterday starting off this morning with
some 60's and 70s summer solstice
tomorrow morning 2 13 a.m our time june
21st longest day of the year 14 and a
half hours of daylight all right it is
going to be a beautiful day tomorrow but
a little bit warmer we're going to get
back to some triple digits and then
we've got some other changes coming the
middle of the week we'll talk about that
lots of 70s around the valley some 60s
green valley down to 69 mountains edge
at 65 the lakes at 68. it's been a
little breezy out at red rock if you're
heading out there maybe you have the day
off juneteenth is a federal holiday
second year now that we've uh
u.s has observed it as a national
holiday 73 in boulder city we've got 64
in pram 57 in indian springs 77 in
laughlin and look at kingman cool at 54.
20's up the road in ely with 48 in
caliani we'll look for a high of 94
today normal high for june 20th is 101
so we're staying below normal our
record's 117 that's the hottest
temperature we've ever recorded
officially for las vegas officially for
las vegas and we've done that quite a
few times in the month of june and early
july 72 up at mount charleston if you're
going up today there will be some
northwest breezes and out at the lake
those winds up to 15 miles an hour could
be a little higher at times be careful
out of the northeast 95 for the lake
today
cool air coming in from canada right up
around the northern rockies and we'll be
looking for monsoon moisture all the way
east of the four corners through the
rockies and the northern plains if
you're traveling showers from the great
lakes through the ohio valley down to
the virginias today it's kind of putting
a lid on all that excessive heat though
that they've had in the eastern u.s
since last week so for us we've got a
cold front to the south monsoon moisture
to the east but it looks like it's going
to shift maybe over towards the desert
southwest through the week it's all
remnants of these tropical systems off
the coast of mexico and that's where
we'll get our slight chance of showers
and thunderstorms by the middle of the
week 94 today up to 100 tomorrow and
about a 20 percent chance of showers and
maybe some thunder and lightning on
wednesday otherwise we're off to the
races with triple digits from thursday
all the way into next week i think a
long string of days at 105 or hotter